The Joe Rogan Experience what do you
think about the [ __ ] the live golf
thing love it absolutely love it
why not tell me more here's the reason
and I told you before this I know a guy
that went over there uh and I and here's
the thing
some people love the preservation in the
history of the PGA I get it tradition a
lot of things about the PGA are [ __ ]
and particularly the idea that the PGA
had a stronghold on them it was kind of
like it has like the remnants of like
contracts from studios in the 50s for
actors where you're like we own your
[ __ ] ass your likeness your rights
your images when the golfers golf they
can't use that footage they have to
license it from the PGA so if I'm out
playing and I want to be like hey man I
want to put a post on Instagram about
this dope ass putt I hit or whatever
this great you have to buy it you have
to buy your [ __ ] back from them [ __ ]
why if I'm if I'm Zion Williamson in the
NBA and I [ __ ] yoke on something I
put my dick in their [ __ ] face and
dunk on them the NBA can't wait to give
you the footage they're like dude post
that [ __ ] because it's going to help
their brand
PGA is old white guy [ __ ] and it's I
get it that it's Antiquated so some of
the younger guys were like [ __ ] this I
want more freedom and fun I want
something different some of them their
careers are on the
other side so they might not be making
so much more twin money right so this is
a great alternative the problem people
had was like Dustin Johnson or you know
guys that are at the top and they're
like why are you pulling your game over
there you could do you think you you
think you can't win anymore in this
which is part of the controversy it's
like oh you do what's the big
controversy the big controversy the
Saudis yeah but but Saudi money is
invested in uh tons of [ __ ] look up uh
look up look up Saudi look up Saudi
money LPGA look that up
uh the sound the the investment of the
Saudis isn't like a new thing in
American Sports so it's this is people
are just mad because the PGA
particularly is mad because they look
they're looking something in the face
that's threatening them it's not going
to be bigger than the PGA but it's an
alternative that's fun people like it I
it's not going to be bigger not going to
take it over but they don't what people
are concerned with is that people are
leaving and they're going to work for
someone who's been accused of some
horrific [ __ ] sure but who made your
jeans
these are American but you know what I
mean it's like most people made by
origin but most people go oh dude I
don't like that it's like you're made
your [ __ ] shirt was made by a Chinese
kid there's a lot well your phone if
you're complaining about stuff you're
literally complaining on a device that
was made by slaves but that's my point
so I think that when somebody when you
start to get into nitpicky stuff I'm
always like um
I understand the idea of like being like
people are anti them playing for Saudi
money but you if you think you're not
involved in Saudi money at a high Sports
level I'm sorry but it's there well the
WWE fans are freaking out now right why
Jamie yeah yeah what's that about
announced last night that the Saudi
Investment fund bought the WWE I believe
okay
well what are you gonna do happens now I
don't know yeah I don't know if I can
know what happens now well there's no
Divas there's gonna be any women yeah
Vince McMahon WWE Talent done if company
is sold to Saudi Arabia thank you
brother it says it's not sold to Saudi
according to them this is what was
happening on Twitter last night WWE
Twitter World freaked out it was like
trending all night well go to Snopes
what do Snopes have to say oh Dad an
answer oh yeah
is WWE being so research in progress oh
still going so yes so the answer is yes
and they just can't leaking
the money comes around if it's it's a
substantial increase in money I think
here's the deal I I understand tradition
but if these guys want an alternative
League to play in who who [ __ ] let
them go play I don't who gives a [ __ ] I
don't know
why do you need a monopoly of one League
I mean you look at the history that's
not what the problem is what people have
a problem with is Jamal khashoggi Jamal
khashoggi who's a journalist for the
Washington Post who was dismembered at
the Turkish Embassy at the supposedly at
the instructions of the Saudi royals
yeah he was critical of them yeah but I
mean I I don't know man I don't know who
and I don't know who who literally is
funding they could be just Saudi
businessmen that are funding live I
don't know this particulars but I don't
know that's what I'm saying is like
whatever if they want to go play in that
league and they're comfortable with it
let them go play I guess [ __ ] it what an
American perspective well let him go
play it's [ __ ] capitalism baby you
won't get that [ __ ] check that's the
Trump perspective get that [ __ ] check
dude Trump told him it's amazing amazing
organization they're doing great things
doing great things go get that money
I think honestly here's what's really
going to happen
they're going to go get that money and
they're going to leave you then it's
going to be over and it's going to
dissipate into now we're not if they
have that kind of cheddar
well they have enough cheddar they could
literally keep this going forever if
they wanted yeah yeah and you wouldn't
put a dent in them no no it's not that
and you're right it's more that what
guys are going to be willing to either
stay there or continue to go over there
so the problem is the talent right it's
like anything else it's like but they're
having the events here correct I went to
one so you don't have to stay you don't
have to go over there I don't I don't
think they only I think they only play
one over there all of them are here like
I went to one in Chicago Rich Harvest
Farms uh
and yeah I mean I you know look it's
it's really interesting to to see the
internal uproar which I immediately
attribute to
golf is an old tradition sport so people
are really particular so they don't even
like that someone's entering the
conversation the outs the other
perspective obviously is the one that is
the bigger deal is people aren't people
are think it's an immoral move right
unethical move and if it was instead
some enormous hedge fund got together
and they put all their money together
and decided to fund their own
alternative golf agency
just as mad I think they would be just
as upset people the PGA does not want
competition they don't like that guys
are even thinking about going and then I
think personally they're shoehorning in
the Saudi stuff to go and that's bad see
they're more mad about business
interests they don't give a f they don't
[ __ ] care about how much of a effect
is it having on the top players nothing
I mean there my buddy my buddy's doing a
documentary that's coming out on Netflix
uh I think coming up soon in the first
quarter of the Year about
um the PGA and during it during the
middle of filming half of the guys left
and went to live and he films both
perspectives so and it's supposed to be
really good
it's just
it's not changed much what's the the
highest level
player the highest paycheck the highest
lever level like a guy who's like a
championship caliber Phil Mickelson is
one of the greatest of all time arguably
in a in a span of many many golfers I'm
not saying he's like number one or I'm
not saying I'm just saying he is one of
the best of all time and he is the I
think he's the biggest money right
wasn't he the biggest him or DJ yeah him
or DJ got the most but but what kind of
money we're talking about 150 Mills
supposedly to just come over to play
before they want any extra money before
they got paid out whoa yeah but it's
also part of a contract that no one
knows the details of these contracts
well they're private right they don't
have to disclose didn't they lose all
their sponsors once they went over there
though a lot of them a lot of them lost
some of their sponsors but uh I don't
know if you need him anymore after 150
mil clears right yeah I think I think
like what kind of sponsors are we
talking about CDW you know like business
investment firms golf is sponsored
heavily by like you know a TD Ameritrade
and [ __ ] it's a lot of that which makes
sense because all those guys the guys
who like golf yeah businessman old
businessmen they love to do business
meetings on the golf course could you
see a Phil I bet if you're like a
businessman you probably have to play
golf I think some circles it's an
advantage I don't know if the new era
I'm you know I might you know our age is
what's going on now in the Youth of
business I don't [ __ ] know what 22
year olds have to do to like get through
in the corporate world but I imagine
uh it's still a part of it to a degree
you know it's an inner circle that
you're going to get leverage from
somewhere or not it's like going to a
good school it's like dude I went to
Arizona state did I have any connections
I made zero [ __ ] friends I made a lot
of [ __ ] friends but none of them
could help me business-wise it's not
like going to Yale no yeah you go to you
go to an accredited University someone's
daddy is a somebody and so that's a big
advantage in going to a good beat that
guy and you might wind up working for
his firm he might give you a [ __ ] job
yeah you want a job does your kid want
to it's like that [ __ ] but Billy's a
good kid really good kid he's top of his
class I give him a couple hundred grand
a year out of school we'll let him [ __ ]
off for two years then we'll figure it
out show them how to do Coke
we'll give them a bump but so I think I
I like at the end of the day whatever
people whatever those guys want to do
I just want to watch golf so I don't
give a [ __ ] I'm definitely the PGA is
still going to be the number one because
it has you know the Masters it has
tournaments where it's it's just now is
this the general attitude of most people
most people are just letting it go they
don't think most guys people are
outraged most guys my age I think Jamie
might be in a similar boat where you're
like I don't [ __ ] give a [ __ ] but my
dad's generation is like I'm gonna
[ __ ] it's ridiculous okay you don't
have to go supporting the [ __ ] Saudis
and you go over there and you're
abandoning the ship that like you sailed
in on you know the PGA built you and it
Formed you it would be like if the UFC
had a big competitive had a had a
competitive thing come forward with way
more money which I don't know if that's
happened I'm ignorant you could tell me
if it has but it hasn't but if it had
that that's kind of the same thing
there's some guys who get really good
deals that they wouldn't get in the UFC
so what happens is
um if there's Talent that's available
that's Top Flight Talent uh Bellator has
options you know that's an option yeah a
lot of guys will go to Bellator because
Bellator will pay them more but it's
like when you get to the world
championship like the Conor McGregor
khabib nurmagment off level I think they
make more money in the UFC right I think
because they have pay for review excuse
me pay-per-view you don't see
pay-per-view with Bellator I think
they've done a couple pay-per-views I
don't think they've been that successful
whereas UFC does a pay-per-view every
month right every month is an enormous
pay-per-view there's world championship
fights where you get the best of the
best and everybody knows who they are
it's like Q-tips NFL NBA like that's MMA
at the highest level right like you can
get cotton swabs at CVS that aren't made
by Q-tips you're asking for Q-tips
where's the Q-tips where's Kleenex yeah
where's the kleenex and that I mean
that's not even the best example right
because the two tips that you know CVS
that aren't Q-tips the cotton swabs are
probably just as good it's not that
[ __ ] hard to have a little stick and
a little cotton on the end of it but
it's the name to get Elite world-class
fighters to compete in the biggest
organization to hold that UFC belt you
know I have Bruce Buffer say and no you
know when they put that [ __ ] strap on
you whoa that's the the cream of the
crop when it comes to Combat Sports well
that's what it is in the PGA it's like
they hold tradition they're they've got
it by the balls so no one will there's
no uh it's not accredited you know live
is for fun it's for money and fun and I
think they're trying to appeal to like a
a new Young Market I think they need to
do that [ __ ] with the crowd that well
the live is Liv has live music they have
like who has that that one with the
crowd what that's a different PGA that's
the PGA yeah this has got to be the this
is like the one time they kind of let
this chaos go it's because it's in
Phoenix Waste Management runs it it's
it's a great move no it's it's well you
should show him a picture of what the
16th hole looks like without those
stands it what what they build is
mind-blowing the course outside of that
looks nothing like that they build this
huge structure that structure they put
in temporarily yeah that's gone most of
the time it's not there what that's what
it looks like that enormous structure
they built temporarily yes
and they keep it or they take it down
just for the tournament they take it
down the moment the tournament's close
that course goes back to what it looks
look at the 16th without it oh my God
that's insane or 17 is it how many
people are in there I mean dude that's
got to be I don't know thousands five
thousands more yeah it looks like more
if that was a show that we were doing
together we'd be like bro just without
grandstand right without grandstand that
looks like 30 40 000 to me man look
that's what it looks like Joe without it
whoa whoa it's nothing as a time lapse
how many uh people were there
Google the uh what's the the amount the
audience size you're allowed to walk in
and out of that area it's not like you
need a seat yeah you don't stay you can
go anywhere on the course right but how
many people get seeded by those that
that structure they put in place how
many seats are available
take a guess I'm saying 40 Grand I would
say 20K yeah it's like 15 15 or 20K is
my it seems more than that man it does
so there's a lot of boxes too
they sell those boxes it's a 16th old
they sell those boxes because people now
know how fun it is right but what's the
actual number
all changes year to year because they
add more people yeah but they have okay
let's go to 2021
Waste Management Open
crowd size yeah that's it okay there's
got to be a way to find it right yeah
100 I mean they'll give you they'll give
you a an estimate of some they'll give
you like usually how many people show up
because they brag about it
twenty thousand eight thousand but
that's the whole event that's not
sitting yeah but I would argue half of
them are there yeah that's probably 10
20 10 grand maybe but what a great idea
to get it exciting because that was so
much more exciting than a normal golf
you should hear when they interview pro
golfers this is only five thousand five
thousand fans Per Day 2021 this is when
the pandemic was happening oh right
right the grandstands are non-existent
uh pro golfers say that that's the most
nervous they are because people are it's
dead people talk [ __ ] they're yelling
it's dude most times you know they get
this as a guy that holds up a thing to
shut the [ __ ] up yeah there there's no
rules you just can't love that and you
know what's so funny when somebody does
get a hole in one like that they all
throw beer like you can he's got
pictures of it where they'll throw beer
on there but they don't get kicked out
or anything it's like the one time
you're allowed to throw a beer